Hallo Stefan. Wir begegnen uns heute wieder leibhaftig. Nicht nur via Zoom, sondern wir haben ja noch Großes vor.
Wir sitzen vorm Salon am gemeinsamen Tisch.
Genau. Momentan noch du im T-Shirt und in kurzer Hose. Aber wir wollen gucken, ob der Anzug passt. Das werden wir heute mal rausfinden, dann nach dem Salon. Und wir lesen wieder Texte bzw. wir sprechen über Texte, die wir gelesen haben und sind damit vielleicht eine aussterbende Art. Denn ich bringe jetzt mal hier einen Clip aus dem Once and Two's Podcast. Adam Two's bringt mal ein paar Zahlen ins Spiel.
That's one in three. By 2016 the number was only 2%. In the late 1970s, 60% of 12th graders in the US said they read a book or a magazine almost every day. By 2016 only 16% did. And this is despite the fact that we could, you know, you could be talking about digital content. It's just not happening. People are in the world of Tiktok, it used to be once upon a time they're in the world of Facebook or Twitter. And they are not engaging in long-form reading, even in the sense of reading articles in newspapers or magazines. So that's a really dramatic shift.
Ja, wir haben es ja bei uns im Salon stehen. Wir lesen noch, solange geschrieben wird.
Wir lesen noch, solange gelesen wird.
Genau, irgendwas muss dann noch geschrieben und gelesen werden. Und so, wenn weniger gelesen wird, wird natürlich auch weniger geschrieben. Die Buchmesse steht ja an und man kann jetzt schon die Texte erahnen. Die dann immer den Sing-Sang bilden, dass nämlich es dem Buch nicht besonders gut geht. Nicht nur, weil Leute wenig lesen, sondern auch, weil es Papier knapp ist. In der Hinsicht, klar, man weiß dann immer wieder darauf hin, dass so gelesen wird, aber so richtig Auswege und Lösungen bieten sich dann auch nicht. Weil man auch das Problem nicht so richtig versteht. Wir leben, also ich würde ja sagen, auch nach Redaktionsschluss kam ja 2016, dann kam Brexit, dann kam Trump und ich würde sagen, das ist halt die Welt, in der nicht gelesen wird.
Ja.
Und der alle nur noch im Moment, sozusagen so eine Abass-Show. Und Scholz soll dann aber auch antworten, haben wir ja besprochen.
Und viele Affekte, sehr viele Reizreaktionen. Also Tiktok funktioniert genauso wie unsere Zeit funktioniert. Also eigentlich hat das, man kann immer fragen, was bringt was hervor? Aber in gewisser Weise ist es nicht nur so, dass Tiktok neue Subjekte hervorbringt und neue Formen des Reagierens, sondern in gewisser Weise antwortete Tiktok auch schon auf etwas, was vorfindlich war in der Gesellschaft und hat es nur noch dann perfektioniert.
Ja, ich würde ja bei dieser Frage nach generativen Mechanismen und ihrer Macht immer mehr den Fokus auf die Medien legen als in der allgemeinen Diskussion. Wir kennen die Dessertation von Frau Fransky über die Diagnosegesellschaft. Man soll zurückhaltend sein mit Diagnosen, aber wir haben es mit einer Tiktok-Vergesellschaftung zu tun. Die Tiktok-Vergesellschaftung, um den Prozesscharakter noch mal darzustellen. Und naja, es ist traurig. Atom Tours haben wir immer in diesen Momenten, wo es irgendwie so traurig ist. Zu wenig Geld, zu wenig Lesezeit.
Silvio Berlusconi ist jetzt auch bei Tiktok. Und das ist natürlich passend, dass der Medienmogul jetzt auch da mitmischt. Stimmt. Du sprichst aber eigentlich was ganz Interessantes an, denn es kamen doch in den letzten, nach den letzten Folgen immer mal wieder Nachrichten, die mich zum Beispiel auch dann über Insta oder so erreicht haben, dazu, wie man dann damit zurechtkommt, dass wir so viel über Schlimmes reden. Und wir werden ja gleich über ein Buch reden, das sagt, ja, die ganze Welt wird regiert von Autokraten. Und es gibt noch so ein paar Länder, wo das nicht so ist, zum Beispiel Frankreich und Deutschland. Und da geht man ja nicht durch dieses Buch, durch die Seiten durch und sagt, Mensch, das ist aber heiter zu lesen. Und das ist eine Frage, die ich natürlich immer nur individuell beantworten kann. Und zugleich habe ich schon mal gesagt, wir machen hier keine Lebenshilfe, dass man jetzt sagen kann, so muss man es angehen. Ich glaube schon, dass man trennen muss zwischen dem, was passiert in der Welt und dem, was privat einen umgibt. Das kann man nicht voneinander abschneiden, denn das eine bedingt auch irgendwie das andere. Aber ich glaube auch schon, dass es da gilt, sich eine gewisse Souveränität in den eigenen Räumen zu verschaffen. Also da, glaube ich, ist es schon. Und für mich ist es ja, um die dann doch mal individuell zu beantworten, ganz klar die Beschäftigung mit, ich sag's so groß, der Kunst, die mir dann doch sehr hilft, also die mich unglaublich erfreut, die auch zeigt, was eigentlich möglich ist, wozu Menschen noch im Stande sind. Nämlich nicht nur zu irgendwelchen Tiktok-Challenges, sondern ich höre mit Vergnügen das neue Album von Kit Armstrong, also ist schon ein Jahr alt, wo er 500 Jahre alte Klaviermusik, also die eigentlich nicht für das Klavier komponiert war, spielt. Ich sehe mir Videos von ihm bei YouTube an und denke, ja, so ein Wunderkind fing mit sieben Jahren, also er spielte schon Klavier, fing mit sieben Jahren dann auch das Studium der Komposition an, studierte nebenher noch Mathematik und alles Mögliche. Und wie der über Musik redet und dieses verknüpft mit mathematischem, physikalischem Wissen, sowas ist auch etwas, was einem zeigen kann, der Mensch ist zu doch mehr fähig als zu dem, was Donald Trump aus dem Menschen gemacht hat.
Vor allem, es gibt immer alles doppelt, eine Welt draußen und eine Welt drinnen. Und dann kann man, da man über die Welt drinnen sehr viel mitentscheiden kann, über die Welt draußen irgendwie nicht, kann man sich es ein bisschen zurechtbiegen. Und wir lesen heute auch interessante Texte. Zum Beispiel war Douglas Rushkoff eingeladen von Millionären und Milliardären, um über das Ende der Welt zu sprechen, die sich nämlich, und er hat sehr ausführlich gerade darüber geschrieben, auf The Event vorbereiten und an ihrem Mindset arbeiten. Und dann ist die Frage, mit Prepar-Attitüten dadurch zu kommen oder doch einen Bunker brauchen, wie teuer soll der Bunker sein, reichen 40.000 Euro für ein Schlafzimmer oder braucht man so ein 8-Millionen-Menschending unter der Erde? Auf der anderen Seite lesen wir im Economist, wie oder das Ellen Blanden nochmal Johann-Peter-Eckermanns-Gespräche mit Goethe auf Englisch übersetzt hat. Und man nun der Meinung ist, ja, zum einen der Eckermann schrieb auf Deutsch, hat also eher ein, weil er auch keinen Audio-Recorder hatte, um Goethe aufzunehmen, eher ein nachträgliches, impressionistisches Gemälde angefertigt, als eine Fotografie in diesen 700 Seiten, in denen wir Goethe kennenlernen. Und jetzt liegt das eben auch für die englischsprachige Welt noch mal so vor, dass die Urteile lauten, ja, das wird jetzt so der deutschen Ausgabe gerecht. Man kann es jetzt endlich mal auch weltweit lesen und so. Und das passt irgendwie ganz gut zusammen, weil auf der einen Seite diese Milliardäre, die dann irgendwie feststellen, es gibt kein Exit. Die Erde ist leider die Erde und Neuseeland ist auch nicht so weit. Und auf der anderen Seite sitzen die Leute in ihren Schreibstuben und befassen sich noch mal mit 150 Jahre alten Dialogen und versuchen sie so schön wie es geht, aus dem Material zu schnitzen, das eben vorliegt. Wohl wissend, original liegt es eh nicht vor, also können wir hier auch noch ein bisschen den Tusch dazu geben. So und jetzt muss man sich entscheiden, auf welche Seite schlägt man sich. Ist man zufrieden damit, den Goethe noch mal gut zu lesen? Oder spart man jetzt schon drauf und macht den frugalen Lebensstil, um dann irgendwann in zehn Jahren, wenn The Event kommt, mit dem Mindset so weit zu sein, dass man bereit ist, auf 30 Quadratmeter unterirdisch zu leben?
Und was ist das dann für ein Leben?
Genau, also die Welt da draußen, die Welt da drin. Irgendwo kann man sich schon einrichten, man muss jetzt Banden bilden und ich hab's auch hier in meinem Blick. Schirmachers Minimum ist ja auch so ein Buch, das vor über 20 Jahren diese Fragen schon mal stellte. Welches kleine soziale Gefüge brauche ich, um in diesem großen Wirrwarr klarzukommen? Und das stellt halt einige Fragen. Die kann man ja für sich dann einfach beantworten. Und ich würde sagen, ein Podcast ist so ein persönliches Medium, dass man sich über die Welt verständigt, aber gleichzeitig innen, in dieser Innenwelt, in dieser sozialen, hier kann ich noch was tun, nämlich selber entscheiden. Erstens will ich den Podcast hören, zweitens wann will ich ihn hören, wie will ich ihn hören. Man kann uns kennenlernen und so weiter. Also wir sind sozusagen gar nicht so weit die Außerwelt, sondern wir sind ganz schön viel Innenwelt. Also da steckt doch auf vielen Ebenen so ein bisschen Trost drin. Den kann man dann auch annehmen, finde ich, statt irgendwie auf Twitter traurig zu sein über den Zustand der Welten.
Ja, Trost ist ein gutes Wort. Ich habe wirklich ein Gedicht noch mitgebracht, nicht von Mia, keine Sorge, sondern von Jean-Henri Mackay. Der hat es geschrieben, vertont hat es Richard Strauss. Und ich empfehle jedem, das sich anzuhören, morgen von Richard Strauss gesungen, am besten von Joyce DiDonato. Aber es gibt unglaublich tolle Interpretationen bei YouTube zu finden. Und dieses Gedicht geht so. Und morgen wird die Sonne wieder scheinen. Und auf dem Wege, den ich gehen werde, wird uns, die Glücklichen, sie wieder einen, inmitten dieser sonnenatmenden Erde. Und zu dem Strand, dem weiten Wogen blauen, werden wir still und langsam niedersteigen. Stumm werden wir uns in die Augen schauen und auf uns sinkt des Glückes Stummess schweigen. Dringend anhören. Und jetzt kommen wir zu den hässlichen Dingen des Lebens, denn ich habe einen Ausschnitt aus einer aktuellen Trump-Rede mitgebracht, der jetzt schon mal den Salon anteasert, denn wir hören folgendes von Trump...
Diese sind wie zentrale Casting. Es gibt niemanden, der den Ruf in Hollywood spielen könnte. Alle von Hollywood, niemanden kann den Ruf von Präsident Xi in China spielen. Und dann habe ich ihn eine Frage gefragt und ich sagte, er ist Präsident für das Leben, übrigens. Er sagte, aber ich bin kein King.
Wie bestellt die eiserne Faust, die noch mal gelobt wird, die 1, 5 Milliarden Menschen regiert? Und das wird ja von Gideon Ruffman auch beschrieben, diese Connection zwischen diesen Autokraten, obwohl sie ja eigentlich auch sich zum Beispiel als Systemfeinde verstehen könnten. Denn zugleich haben wir ja diese ganzen China-China-Autsagen von Trump im Ohr, wo er ja ganz klar China als den Systemrivalen uns konturiert, um aber zugleich zu sagen, aber wie da regiert wird. Das finde ich schon irgendwie smart.
Ja, das greift ja der Rachman gut auf, diese Schizophrenie, gerade von Trump. Auf der einen Seite diese Bewunderung für diese Person, weil sie ihm so in den Arsch treten können. Und er weiß, zu diesem Club gehöre ich nicht. Haben wir ja eben gehört, diese Regierungszeit auf Lebenszeit, die ja dann Ende 2022 irgendwie auch hier nochmal angekündigt wird im Buch. Oh man, Trump.
The Age of the Strongman heißt das Buch. Und wir haben jetzt eine, oder wir nicht, aber die Briten haben eine neue Premierministerin. Nun, Liz Truss, was ist zu ihr zu sagen? Vielleicht hören wir mal in einen Clip hinein. Es wird im Salon ja auch um Identitätspolitik gehen. Ich verspreche da schon mal jetzt ganz Großes. Also es ist ein enorm großer Wurf, der Omri Böhm da geglückt ist. Und wir können da bestimmt daran anknüpfen, wenn wir jetzt Liz Truss bei einer Rede hören, wie sie England wieder fit machen will.
Ich möchte sehen, wie wir mehr britische Füße hier in Briten essen. Das ist ein Schlamm!
Fehlt nur noch das Wort, ist Teil unserer Identität. Also jetzt wird Apfel-Identitätspolitik hier betrieben. Und man muss darauf hinweisen, das ist jetzt die Premierministerin von Großbritannien, die jetzt hier eine Rede hält und darüber redet, was man mal importieren könnte oder nicht mehr exportieren sollte. Und auch in der Art, wie sie das vorträgt, vielleicht bekommen wir hier eine noch merkwürdigere Version von Boris Johnson oder so. Weil da irgendjemand sich freut, dass Boris Johnson weg ist. Ich würde sagen, ganz vorsichtig. Sie ist ja auch eine neoliberale Hardlinerin, was Steuererleichterung für Reiche anbelangt und und und.
Aber der Clip ist ein bisschen älter. Sie sagt das hier nicht als Premierministerin, aber sie ist es jetzt. Jetzt iss ich's.
Vielen Dank. Ist auch ein bisschen so Annegret Crumb-Carnbauer mäßig.
In einem Fortnight geh ich nach Paris für die weltweit größte Futterveranstaltung und ich werde die britischen Produkte aufbauen.
Ja, so könnte die neue Politik dann aussehen. Aber wir wissen ja auch, es gibt diese alberne Frage, kann er Kanzler oder kann sie Premierministerin? So was stellt sich dann jetzt auch. Und Liz Truss wird hier folgendermaßen befragt.
Du wirst in einer Runde, sehr privat, bei Nummer 10, vor dir liegen, was die Letzten des letzten Resorts sind.
Deine Order zu unserem Trident-Boot-Kampion, ob du, Herr Minister von der Truss, die Order gibt, unsere nukleare Waffen zu entleuchten, das bedeutet globales Verbrechen.
Wie macht dich das Gefühl?
Ich glaube, es ist eine wichtige Aufgabe des Prime Ministers.
Auf die Strong Men folgt das Zeitall der Strong Women. Ja, möglicherweise. Den Siegsmens schon.
Die auch bereit sind, den Atomkrieg zu starten. Tolle Qualifikation.
Also über die Strong Men ist ja zu sagen und ich greife Ihnen nur kurz voraus, Bolsonaro hat Mitarbeiter in seinem Kreise, die sich nicht davor zurückschrecken, auch öffentlich und zitierbar zu sagen, der Präsident hat mal wieder einen Haufen Scheiße geredet. Weil das interessiert eh keinen, was irgendwer aus der Hinterreihe sagt. Und dann sagt man wenigstens den Journalisten noch mal, das war einfach scheißes Präsidenten. So ist das hier auch. So redet man nicht über Atomwaffen auf der Bühne, außer man hat so Strong Woman Attitüden. Und das Idee hat, die sich ja an dem Käse- und Apfel- und Pork-Clip herauslesen, denn dieser identitätspolitischen Bezüge auf unser und der anderen Güter scheint ja nun die DNA zu sein, die alle hier übergreift. Und wir würden ja, also uns werden ja einige gleich vorgestellt in dem Buch.
Ja, wir sprechen über Welt der Autokraten von Gideon Rachman. Dann spreche ich über die Autobiografie von Werner Herzog, dem großen deutschen Filmregisseur. Außerdem ein, wie ich schon sagte, großer Wurf des Philosophen Omri Boehn, radikaler Universalismus jenseits von Identität. Also dieser Philosoph mischt sich in diese Identitätspolitik-Debatte von rechts und von links ein und gibt eine vollkommen überraschende Antwort, sagt, ne, auch die, die jetzt gerade sagen, wir verteidigen eigentlich den Liberalismus, verteidigen ihn nicht. Die Identitätspolitiker, die sagen, wir sollten das lieber markant nicht mehr lesen, weil der sich ja rassistisch geäußert hat, die alle irren. Er sagt, was eigentlich Universalismus bedeutet, inwieweit auch der Universalismus der Aufklärung widerspricht, also wie man das nicht einfach so zusammen denken kann. Und ich bin wirklich fasziniert, dass man auf 160 Seiten eine solch wunderbare, großartige, kluge Argumentation ausbreiten kann. Darum wird es also gehen. Ich werde schwärmen. Und außerdem habe ich noch drei kleinere Texte. Einmal in Duisburg endet, wie wir wissen, die Seidenstraße. Aber diese Seidenstraße führt auch durch Russland und das kann dann mitunter etwas hakelig werden. Da versucht man jetzt etwas Neues zu finden. Dann sagt eine Ökonomin in der FAZ in einem Interview, das im Übrigen nicht online steht, sondern wirklich nur in der gedruckten Version zu finden ist, wir werden ärmer. Sie spricht über Rezession, über Lieferwege und so weiter. Wir müssen uns diese merkwürdige Argumentation mal ansehen oder vielleicht auch mal Schlüsse daraus ziehen, was das dann eigentlich bedeutet, wenn wir ärmer werden sollen. Und ich hatte gezögert, aber ich mach's jetzt doch. Wir blicken mal ganz kurz nach Frankreich, was sich da in Sachen Corona tut. Aber es wird ganz unpolemisch, ich verspreche es. Ich will es nur reportieren mit einem Artikel aus der Zeit.
Sehr gut, sehr gut. Oh, die Zeit, ich hab sie eben abgeholt. Sie stapelt sich hinter mir, weil ich natürlich im Urlaub das e-Paper, so kein e-Paper, sondern das echte Papier. Jetzt kommt man nach Hause, da liegen drei Zeits da. Wir lesen Chacey Connerboy, ist eine Frau, sie hat ein Buch geschrieben über The Mother Brain, also das Muttergehirn und neue Neuroscience, also neue Gehirnwissenschaft. Mit der ganz großen Fragestellung gibt es so was wie mütterlichen Instinkt oder wurde er erfunden für das Argument Sozialpolitik, wir haben doch Mütter. Und das ist eine so wunderbare Aufarbeitung. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob das ein Vorabdruck ist, also ein Auszug aus dem Buch oder ob die New York Times sie gebeten hat, noch mehr exklusiv für sie zu formulieren. Es tat mir ein bisschen weh, diesen Text zu lesen und zu wissen. Schade, er findet in meinem Buch keine Erwähnung mehr. Er hätte wunderbar ins Familienkapitel am Ende nochmal gepasst mit so vielen Hinweisen, so viel Geschichtsschreibung, die hier nochmal neu aufgezogen wird. Also ganz großartig. Dann auf Leserempfehlung. Douglas Rushkoff ist ein Tausendsasser der Publizistik, der also eingeladen wurde von Milliardären und Millionären. Und er schreibt so ein bisschen darüber, wie das ist, sich mit deren Exit-Mindset und die Event-Ängsten zu beschäftigen. Dann geht es ums Barfußlaufen und um Goethe.
Prima. Dann sehen wir uns im Salon. Wir wollen noch darauf hinweisen, weil das jetzt schon mal angemerkt wurde, das gesamte Salonarchiv, wenn man wirklich alles noch mal nachhören möchte und nachvollziehen möchte, das gibt es nur so über Steady. Denn das wäre eine Herkules-Aufgabe. Ich wollte gerade fast sagen für uns, aber ich kann natürlich gar nichts dazu. Ich könnte es höchstens löschen, vermutlich in meiner technischen Blöde. Also eine Herkules-Aufgabe für Stefan, das jetzt da alles überall hochzuladen. Also das ist bei Steady und Steady ist auch die günstigste und vielleicht schönste Möglichkeit, Salonmitglied zu werden. Aber Bequemlichkeit ist auch toll und ich kann es ja so nachvollziehen. Ich bin auch sehr, sehr bequem bei ganz vielen Dingen. Deshalb, wer den Podcast eh über Apple hört, kann auch den Salon über Apple abonnieren. Hat dann nicht ein Riesenarchiv, sondern nur die letzten, glaub ich acht Folgen oder so sind es. Dann bei Patreon werden jetzt nach und nach die neuen Folgen natürlich dann immer kommen, aber nicht mehr das gesamte Archiv. Aber auch darüber ist der Salon buchbar. Und bei Spotify ist es sowieso jetzt relativ leicht, in den Salon zu kommen, weil da ein Button ist, der einen dann mit Steady connectet, sodass man da auch Zugang zu allem dann hat.
Genau, es gibt inzwischen sehr viele komfortable Wege in den Salon, aber nur einer ist auch wirklich komplett. Und das ist der Steady-Weg. Hier also nochmal der Hinweis. Wir haben uns nicht schuldig gemacht, nicht ausführlich genug darauf hinzuweisen. Diese kleine Anklage kamen via Twitter, sondern wir haben immer dazu gesagt, das ganze Archiv nur bei Steady. Und jetzt haben wir es auch nochmal gesagt.
Prima, dann sehen wir uns im Salon mit vielen interessanten Texten.
Bis gleich!